hi everyone it's jerry this is game
seven from the 2021 fiji world chess
championship match between yan
yapomnichi playing on the white end
and magnus carlson
going into game seven carlson leads
three and a half two and a half in this
race to seven and a half
let's have a look
opening wise yet again e4 by nir
ponnichi all e4s in his white games
all odd number games he's playing with
the white pieces throughout this match
and we follow game five
we have the same ten moves
as in game five so let's get to this
point right here
now in game five
play followed with
c3
black went with b4
looking forward to opening up the b file
and then white went with the d3
in this game it's d3 straight away so
some differences compared to game five
the b file will not as easily be opened
up
black is not able to advance and engage
with the c pawn in this case
and c3 remains vacant for the queen
knight
this is a new option
from here a standard move by black
flight square watchful eye over night
jumps
or bishop move
knight c3 follows
and from here this is the first think of
this game seven we have rook to e8
another standard move looking for
the
tucking away of the bishop opening up
the e7 square for the knight to transfer
towards the king side
uh another move that was likely being
considered by carlson at this stage
is
knight to b4 so this is a nice move to
be familiar with
it's one that did not initially cross my
mind
when running the live stream today
um but
and i i think that that was the case
because this isn't a hole
um
you know at some point c3 could come but
it's it's timely
in that you can't scare the knight away
just yet
it's helping to fight for control over
d5 which is clearly in
in in white's future that's that's the
main square white has
his sights set on after knight c3
and
nearby c5 is the move
right so if let's say knight to e2 black
is able to get this c pawn rolling this
is
probably the main point behind initially
making the knight move sure it watches
over d5 but we want to clear the way for
the c pawn to contribute
and to have an influence in the center
of the board
anyhow a nice move to keep in mind
in this game it's rook to e8
knight d5
the bishop backs off
and
and
black wants to be in a position to
simply recapture we do have
white initiate the capture on f6
queen recapturing of course
keeping the structure as is
white's preparing to build in the center
with
d4 and knight to e7 so there was another
thing on this move 15
with knight to e7
blacken needs to be prepared to meet
rook a7
all right when 97 is in there the knight
is no longer controlling this so in the
event of
rook a7 how is black going to meet this
threat
well the pawn would simply move
and
yeah this is
this would be the way forward there's
some care black needs to take over the
d5 square that's the big weakness after
c5 but
that's how black would parry the threat
against the c7 pawn you simply give it a
push
okay
no rook a7
in this one it's more development bishop
to e3
bishop to e6
and now an instructional moment
after this move 17
d4 on board
the structure can change in
a couple different ways here
nearby for white
is
the possibility of establishing a pawn
on black side of the board
and this will have an influence on the
quality of blacks minor pieces rooks
how to deal with this possibility d5
not only space but in this particular
case nearby it's going to be hitting
with tempo
black comes up with
a plan
that's pretty direct
it's it's going to give some direction
to white and not give white a
a wide variety of options he's going to
generate some threats so let's see
black's approach here first
he initiates the capture on d4
in the game
c takes d4 was played
keeping this duo around
uh if the bishop there's there's a few
different ways to capture if you take
with the queen that's bad you lose the
peace but let's have a quick look at the
peace recaptures first
if the bishops recapturing this really
isn't
causing black any problems the queen
gets out of trouble
if bishop takes bishop the queen
recaptures things are fine for black
here
if the knight
recaptures this is one
to touch on i found it interesting that
in this position
with the peace recapture with the knight
recapture on d4
black can make any move
with these pawns right here and they're
all
they're all pretty good
b4 is
a gambit
c5 is a gambit
c6 just remains solid
and the one i like of them all is d5
in this position
which is carving out a square for the
knight on e7
currently the knight on e7 is boxed out
temporarily
black is down a pawn but it'll soon be
hunted
and this knight will soon occupy a
tremendous outpost on d5
anyhow want to give a
an idea of a way forward from that
position
in this game it's
the recapture with the pawn a duo is
present
once again
possibility for a space invader pawn
with d5 temp tempo gainer
black side steps sidesteps that there
will be no d5 with tempo we can say that
for sure the light square bishops have
been exchanged
the queen is promoted she's developed
but no d5 with tempo
and now after this knight move there's a
threat on e4
and it's not easy to deal with
it's
it's uncomfortable
you could go into a strict prevent right
you could you could defend like this
but black has some active plan
and this active plan
involves getting this c pawn rolling
and it turns towards a
a binoni-like structure black will have
a majority
a b and c pawn versus the b-pawn
nearby
so
instead of
watching over this pawn
uh
instead of making a strictly defensive
move white
goes after the c pawn
keeps this rook on the open file
doesn't want to defend e4 white is
prepared to exchange the center pawn
and get this c5 pawn
black doesn't allow this
in this position black plays c5
and this is where you see this f8 bishop
which currently wasn't really a
contributor
it now contributes it's having an
influence on
uh the center
because it's helping to support the c5
pawn however indirect that is
if instead of c5
if black captures on e4 and we have this
trade
you know white is it it's still okay for
black but
you know we're nearing a position where
white starts to have some pressure on f7
there's there's some coordination there
so
instead it's
c5
black in a way saying i don't want you
to establish
a rook on the seventh rank so easily
and there's still a problem on e4 that
you have to address
so from here we have
e5 this is really the last attempt in
this center
to try and stir up some trouble to try
and keep some imbalance
with the pawns
but it's not easy
to do that if if
e5 is the best try in order to cause
some trouble cause some imbalance
if instead of e5 white goes with this
variation there's really not much
happening because
we have simply
a b pawn
but everything is
everything is the same here
nothing fancy on the king side
structurally
fourth rank b pawn for black this guy's
still home not much to play for
um everything's defended well enough
so nothing exciting there
and so therefore e5 is the better
attempt at getting an imbalance
after e5 the reply here is
queen to f5
this is a very strong move
uh
if you capture on e5
white is able to take on c5 and we have
some imbalance
four versus three
on the king side tipping in black's
favor but we have now this passer
potentially a connected passer
probably not a good path to go down if
you're playing as black
and if instead of
this capture if
if white takes like well you can't take
like this you have to do something about
your queen right now so yeah that that's
that's the main one either you're either
taking here moving the queen it is best
to move the queen
f5 is considered a best square
and now a couple options how exactly to
take
like this like that
in the game we had
d takes c5
and the recapture on c5
if we have a look at a different capture
this one right here this would not be
good for white
can you spot a good follow-up move for
black in the event of e takes d6
feel free to pause the video
okay a good move here is not to
recapture but instead insert this c4
move
gain a tempo against the queen and
basically embarrass the rook on c1
a piece that now currently bites on a
rock
in only one move later you go ahead and
well at least attempt to track down this
pawn
during the live stream i thought to
myself you would track that pawn down by
centralizing the queen that's a really
good post and only then taking the
bishop
this is an all right move
as a follow up but it does allow white
to try and exchange queens with queen c5
considered best however is to
put the rook on that square the queens
are still around and black can
look forward to more than a draw in this
position
this would be problematic for
white
if you take on d6
in this position
so it is instead d takes c5
recapture on c5
bishop takes c5
and an important moment is this one
right here so
this is coming down to technique white
uh black wants to keep things simple
uh you know he has an advantage in the
match no need to complicate a draw is a
fine result playing as black
what is the clean approach this is the
last
question
really to answer in this position the
clean approach
to this game
do you capture the bishop
do you capture the pawn
let me throw this
as a pop quiz to you to see what you
would play
white to move which of these two
captures is the cleaner
approach feel free to pause the video
okay
the cleanest approach
is the one played in the game bishop
takes bishop
and only after the recapture do we have
knight takes pawn
now why is this
well if you start with first knight
takes e5
this allows white
to keep the tricky piece around
put the knight on d5
it still holds as around an evenish
position but
there's a tricky night around
there's still maybe some
play here
but
by capturing the bishop
which on the surface doesn't seem like a
good choice because the rook is promoted
to a very active square
helping to defend the pawn as well maybe
there's a pin against the queen
the idea here is that now after knight
takes e5
the exchange of knights is not easily
ducked
there is no knight d4 in this position
because knight f3 would follow
that's a check
and then the rook would fall
so this is nice clean technique at this
final key moment in the middle game
if something fancy is tried by white in
this case
such as
uh well this isn't the fancy move just
yet let me point out rook takes b5 is
bad because knight takes knight check
and then you win the rook
but
maybe a clever move
such as king h1 now the knight is in a
pin is this a great inconvenience for
black it is not
black can get out of the pin with queen
f4
and
there's nothing to play for here
queen if rook takes pawn this is bad
news for white this is losing for white
knight takes knight we're threatening
mate
queen takes knight we would exchange
queens and then get the rook
pawn takes knight we would take the rook
and then take this pawn and yeah big
trouble for white
so
can't avoid the knight exchange
is what i'm getting at
since
black kicked off with bishop takes c5
first
so the knights are exchanged
the rooks are exchanged
and queen c3 is
pretty much an implied draw offer
the queens are now exchanged and since
these guys are
uh
on up not on the same file they're
easily hunted by the rooks
these guys eventually get exchanged
and this is of course a drawn position
but
they are not able to agree to a draw
until 40 moves have been played that's
one of the rules so
they just get these nothing moves in
to get to move
number 41
in the end this is
uh the final one rook a7
uh a draw has been agreed in this game
seven
so some fight in that middle game
near pomneichi trying to stir up some
trouble with that pawn play but black
found a a very nice
way forward
neutralized any
uh
possibility of a great imbalance
and
we go on to game eight this was another
very high quality game as you will see
let's have a look at
how the tail the tape on this one
there we go
yep all goose eggs on this one
41 moving counter
uh all zeros wherever you look
well inaccuracies mistakes and blunders
all zeros
average centipan laws a two
for each side
so
at the end of the day what do we have
the match app
four
to three in favor of carlson going into
game eight
anyhow as usual feel free to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below hope you enjoyed it and
maybe took a thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye
you